Qu'est ce que la bioénergie? La bioénergie ce n'est pas l'éthanol.
La bioénergie ce n'est pas le réchauffement climatique. La bioénergie c'est
quelque chose qui semble contre-intuitif. La bioénergie
c'est le pétrole. C'est le charbon. Et elle contribue à créer
ce pont vers le futur, jusqu'au point où nous
puissions réellement voir les océans d'une manière rationnelle, ou
envoyer des objets en orbite géo-stationnaire qui tournoieront ou
émettront des micro-ondes ou des choses comme ça, dépendra de la façon
dont nous comprendrons la bioénergie et comment nous la gérerons. Et pour ce faire,
intéressons-nous d'abord à l'agriculture.
On a planté des trucs depuis onze mille ans. Et
dans la mesure où on plante ces trucs, on apprend que
l'agriculture c'est gérer les "nuisibles",
il faut gérer toutes sortes d'affreux machins,
il faut cultiver des denrées. Dans la mesure où
on apprend à utiliser l'eau pour les cultures, on
peut alors s'étendre au-delà du Nil.
On pourra être capable d'actionner des machines, donc l'irrigation
peut faire la différence.
L'irrigation est le point de départ qui nous permet de planter
des trucs où on le veut et non pas où les
rivières débordent. On peut alors commencer cette
agriculture organique, on commence à ajouter de la machinerie
à ces trucs. La machinerie, avec énormément d'eau,
mène à l'agriculture à très large échelle.
Quand on met ensemble des machines et de l'eau, on obtient
des paysages qui ressemblent à ça. Ensuite on a des
ventes qui ressemblent à ça. C'est de la force brute. Donc
ce qu'on a fait en agriculture c'est débuter
avec quelque chose qui est un système raisonnablement
naturel. On commence à domestiquer ce système naturel. On
met beaucoup de force derrière ce système naturel. On
met tout un tas de pesticides et d'herbicides --
(rires) -- dans ce système naturel, et on
finit avec un system qui ressemble à ça.
Et ce n'est que de la force brute. Et ça c'est la façon dont nous avons
approché l'énergie. Donc, la leçon que nous pouvons tirer
de l'agriculture c'est qu'on peut vraiment changer le
système qui était basé sur la force brute en commençant à
fusionner ce système, en étudiant ce système et
en lui appliquant la biologie. Et on passe d'une
discipline d'ingénieur, on passe d'une
discipline de chimie à une discipline de
de biologie. Et probablement, l'un des plus important êtres humains
sur cette planète est le gars derrière moi.
C'est un type qui s'appelle Norman Borlaug. Il a obtenu le
Prix Nobel [Prix Nobel de la paix en 1970]. Il a eu la Médaille d'Honneur
du Congrès. Il mérite tout ces trucs. Il les mérite
parce qu'il a probablement nourri
plus de monde qu'aucun autre être humain vivant
car il cherchait comment mettre de la biologie derrière
les graines. Il a fait ça au Mexique. La raison qui fait que l'Inde
et la Chine n'ont plus de famines massives, c'est
que Norman Borlaug leur a enseigné comment cultiver
les céréales d'une manière plus efficace et a mis en route la
"Révolution Verte". C'est quelque chose que beaucoup
de gens ont critiqué. Mais bien sûr, ce sont ceux
qui n'ont pas réalisé que la Chine et l'Inde,
au lieu d'avoir d'innombrables personnes affamées,
sont des exportateurs de céréales.
Et toute l'ironie de cette histoire c'est que
le pays où il fit ses recherches, qui était le Mexique,
n'adopta pas cette technologie, ignora cette
technologie, devisa sur les raisons de réfléchir
à cette technologie mais ne l'appliqua pas vraiment.
Et le Mexique reste l'un des plus grand importateurs de grains
de la planète parce qu'il n'applique pas une
technologie qui fût découverte au Mexique. En
fait, il n'a pas reconnu cet homme, au point
qu'il n'y a aucune statue de cet homme au
Mexique. Il y en a en Chine et en Inde.
L'institut que ce gars dirigeait a déménagé
en Inde. C'est la différence entre adopter
des technologies et discuter des technologies.
Mais la question n'est pas seulement le fait de nourrir énormément de
gens à travers le monde. C'est aussi l'effet
net en termes de ce que la technologie fait si vous
comprenez la biologie.
Qu'est ce qui est arrivé à l'agriculture? Bien, si on prend
l'agriculture tout au long d'un siècle, l'agriculture de
1900 aurait été reconnaissable par quelqu'un
qui plantait mille ans plus tôt. Oui, les charrues semblent
différentes. Les machines étaient des tracteurs ou des choses comme ça
au lieu de mules, mais le fermier aurait
compris ce que le type faisait, pourquoi
il le faisait, ce qu'il en espérait. Ce qui
a réellement commencé à changer l'agriculture fût
lorsqu'on passa de cette force brute
de la mécanique et de la chimie à la biologie. Et c'est
là que votre productivité augmente. Et à mesure
que l'on fait ces changements, voilà ce qui arrive
à la productivité.
Pour faire simple, on passe de 250 heures pour produire
2,5 tonnes, à 40, à 15 jusqu'à 5. La productivité
du travail agricole a été multipliée par sept entre 1950 et 2000
alors que dans le même temps le reste de l'économie n'augmentait que de
2,5 fois. C'est une augmentation absolument massive
de la production par personne.
L'effet de tout cela n'est pas, bien sûr, seulement
des "vagues ambrées de grains" ("amber waves of grain", paroles de la chanson patriotique "America the Beautiful"), c'est des montagnes de denrées.
Et 50 % du budget de l'Union Européenne va subventionner
l'agriculture pour des montagnes de denrées que les gens
ont sur-produit.
Ce serait une bonne issue pour l'énergie.
Et bien sûr vous vous dîtes à présent
"Mais je croyais être venu à une conférence sur
l'énergie et ce gars ne parle que de biologie."
Donc où est le lien entre ces deux choses?
Une des ironies de tout ce système c'est que nous
discutons de ce qu'il faut faire d'un système que nous ne
comprenons pas. Nous ne savons même pas ce qu'est le pétrole.
Nous ne savons pas d'où vient le pétrole. Je veux dire,
littéralement, qu'on continue de débattre de ce qu'est
cette espèce de rivière noire et d'où elle vient.
La meilleure hypothèse, et une des meilleures
suppositions à son sujet, c'est que ce truc vient
de ces machins. Ces choses absorbent
la lumière du soleil, pourrissent sous pression pendant des millions
d'années et vous vous retrouvez avec ces rivières noires.
Maintenant, ce qui est intéressant dans cette thèse -- si
cette thèse se révèle être vraie -- c'est que le pétrole,
comme tous les hydrocarbures, s'avère être
de la lumière solaire concentrée. Et si vous pensez à
la bioénergie, la bioénergie n'est pas l'éthanol. La bioénergie c'est
prendre le soleil, le concentrer dans des amibes,
le concentrer dans des plantes, et c'est peut-être pourquoi
on a ces arcs-en-ciel.
Et si vous regardez ce système, si les
hydrocarbures sont de la lumière solaire concentrée, alors
la bioénergie marche d'une manière différente. Et nous devons
commencer à penser au pétrole ainsi qu'aux autres hydrocarbures comme
des parties de ces panneaux solaires.
C'est peut-être une des raisons qui font que si vous survolez
le Texas occidental, les types de puits que vous
allez voir ne semblent pas différents de ces images
du Kansas et ces terrains irrigués.
C'est ainsi qu'on cultive le pétrole. Et lorsqu'on pense
à cultiver du pétrole et à comment le pétrole a évolué, nous avons commencé
avec cette approche de force brute. Et alors, qu'avons-nous
appris? Alors nous avons appris que nous devions voir plus grand. Et
qu'avons-nous appris? Que nous devions voir encore
plus grand. Et nous devenons vraiment destructeurs quand
nous nous mettons à cultiver cette bioénergie.
Ce sont les sables bitumeux d'Athabasca, et il y en a là
d'énormes quantités -- d'abord à extraire, les plus grands
camions du monde travaillent là-bas, puis
vous devez extraire cette boue noire, qui est
essentiellement du pétrole qui ne coule pas. Il est attaché au
sable. Et puis vous devez utiliser beaucoup de vapeur
pour les séparer, ce qui n'est possible qu'au prix
actuel du pétrole.
Le charbon. Le charbon se trouve être virtuellement la même
chose. Il s'agit probablement de plantes, mais elles
ont brûlé et ont été broyées sous pression.
Donc vous prenez quelque chose comme ça, vous le brûlez, vous
le mettez sous pression, et aussi improbable qu'il puisse paraître, vous vous retrouvez
avec ça. Bien que, ici encore, et j'insiste : nous ne savons pas.
Ce qui est curieux puisque nous débattons de tout ça. Mais
puisque l'on pense au charbon, voilà à quoi ressemblent
des grains de blé brûlés. Pas très différent du charbon.
Et bien sûr les mines de charbon sont des endroits très
dangereux, parce que dans certaines de ces mines de charbon
il y a des gaz. Quand ces gaz explosent, des gens meurent. Donc
on produit un biogaz à partir de charbon dans certaines
mines mais pas dans d'autres.
A chaque fois que vous voyez un différentiel, c'est qu'il y a
d'intéressantes questions. Il y a des questions à propos
de ce que l'on devrait faire de ce truc, Mais,
ici encore, le charbon. Peut-être la même matière, peut-être le même
système, peut-être de la bioénergie et l'on applique
exactement la même technologie.
Ici nous voyons l'usage de la force brute. Dès que l'on se sert
de la force brute, on arrache
des sommets entiers de montagnes. Et on se retrouve
avec la plus grande source d'émissions de carbone,
qui sont les usines qui brûlent du charbon pour produire du gaz. Ce n'est
probablement pas le meilleur usage de la bioénergie.
Lorsque l'on pense aux alternatives à ce
ce système -- il est important de trouver des alternatives,
parce qu'il se trouve que les Etats-Unis sont en train d'épuiser
leurs réserves de pétrole, mais pas
leurs réserves de charbon, la Chine non plus. Il y a d'énormes
réserves de charbon qui attendent là-bas, et
nous devons commencer à les penser comme de l'énergie
biologique, parce que si nous continuons à les traiter comme
de l'énergie chimique ou de l'énergie mécanique, nous
allons nous retrouver dans le pétrin.
Le gaz est un problème similaire. Le gaz est aussi un produit
biologique. Et quand vous pensez au gaz, enfin, vous êtes
familier avec le gaz. Et voila une façon différente
d'extraire le charbon.
On appelle ça le gaz de charbon. Pourquoi cette
photo est-elle intéressante? Parce que si le charbon se révèle
être un concentré de flore, la raison pour laquelle vous pouvez
avoir un différenciel dans la production de gaz entre une mine
et une autre -- la raison pour laquelle une mine peut exploser
et une autre ne pas exploser -- peut-être parce
qu'il y a quelque chose qui mange ce truc et produit du gaz.
C'est un phénomène bien connu. (Rires) Vous
mangez certaines choses, vous produisez beaucoup de gaz. Il
se pourrait que le processus biologique des mines de charbon
suive le même processus. Si c'est vrai, alors
un des moyens d'extraire de l'énergie du charbon
est peut-être de ne pas arracher toute la cime des montagnes, et il
peut-être de ne pas brûler du charbon. C'est peut-être d'avoir des procédés
qui utilisent ce charbon de manière biologique comme
on l'a fait pour l'agriculture.
C'est ce qu'est la bioénergie. Ce n'est pas de l'éthanol. Ce
n'est pas des subventions pour quelques sociétés. Ce n'est pas
l'importation de maïs en Iowa parce que vous avez construit
tellement d'usines à éthanol. On commence à
comprendre la transition que le secteur agricole a connu
de la force brute à la force
biologique. Et dans la mesure où vous pouvez faire cela,
vous pouvez nettoyer certaines choses, et vous pouvez le faire
plutôt rapidement.
Nous avons déjà des indicateurs de productivité là-dessus.
OK, si vous mettez de la vapeur dans les gisements de charbon
ou de pétrole qui ont fonctionné pendant des
décennies, vous pouvez avoir une augmentation
considérable, comme de 800% de la
production. C'est seulement les étapes de commencement de ce
processus.
Et quand vous pensez aux biomatériaux, cet homme -- qui
a contribué au séquençage du génome humain,
qui a doublé les bases de données des gènes et
protéines connus sur terre en naviguant autour du
monde -- a pensé à la façon de structurer
cela. Et il y a plusieurs personnes brillantes
qui pensent à cela. Et ils ont monté
ensemble, des sociétés comme Synthetic Genomics, comme,
a Cambria, comme Codon, et ce que ces sociétés essayent
de faire est de penser à la façon dont on utilise
des principes de biologie pour éviter la force brute?
Pensez-y en ces termes. Pensez-y comme
si on commençait à programmer des choses pour des usages spécifiques
Imaginez les cellules comme du matériel informatique. Imaginez les
gènes comme un logiciel. Et dans la mesure où vous
commencez à imaginer la vie comme un code qui est
interchangeable, cela peut devenir de l'énergie, cela peut
devenir de la nourriture, cela peut devenir des fibres, cela peut
devenir des êtres humains, cela peut devenir toute
sorte de choses. Alors vous devez changer votre
approche en ce qui concerne la façon très différente dont
vous aller structurer et vous occuper
et penser à l'énergie.
Quels sont les premiers principes de ce truc et
où est-ce que nous allons? C'est un des "gentils géants"
sur la planète. C'est l'un des plus gentils êtres
humains que vous ayez jamais rencontré. Son nom est Hamilton
Smith. Il a obtenu le Nobel pour avoir trouvé comment
séparer les gènes -- quelque chose appelé enzymes de restriction.
Il était à Hopkins quand il a fait ça, et c'est
un type si modeste que le jour où il a reçu le Nobel, sa mère
l'a appelé et a dit, "Je ne savais pas qu'il y avait un
autre Ham Smith à Hopkins. Sais-tu qu'il vient de remporter
le Nobel?" (Rires) Enfin, c'était maman.
Mais bon. Cet homme est remarquable. Vous le trouvez
autravail sur la paillasse tous les jours sans exception,
travaillant sur une pipette et construisant des choses. Et voilà
une des choses que cet homme a construites.
Qu'est-ce que c'est? C'est la première transplantation
d'ADN exogène, où on prélève un système ADN entier
à partir d'une seule cellule, on l'insère dans une autre
cellule, et on lance cette cellule comme si elle était d'une
espèce différente. Ça a un mois. Vous verrez des choses arriver
dans le mois qui vient qui vont être aussi importantes
que ce truc.
Et quand vous pensez à ce truc et les
implications que cela comporte, nous allons commencer
non seulement à transformer de l'éthanol à partir du maïs avec
de très importantes subventions. Nous allons commencer à penser à
de l'énergie biologique. C'est très couteux de
développer ces choses-là, tant en termes d'économie
qu'en termes d'énergie.
C'est ça qui s'accumule dans les sables goudronneux
d'Alberta. Ce sont des blocs de souffre. Parce que quand vous
séparez ce pétrole du sable, et utilisez une
quantité énorme d'énergie à l'intérieur de la vapeur --
vapeur pour séparer ces trucs -- vous devez aussi
séparer le souffre du reste. La différence entre
le brut léger et le brut lourd -- alors, c'est environ 14
dollars le barril. C'est pourquoi vous construisez ces
pyramides de bloc de souffre. Et soit dit en passant, l'échelle
de ces choses là est assez grande.
Maintenant, si vous pouvez tirer une partie de l'énergie
de ce processus, vous réduisez le système, et vous
commencez vraiment à appliquer les principes biologiques à
l'énergie. Cela doit être un pont vers le point où
vous pouvez passer à l'éolien, du point où vous pouvez
passer au solaire, du point où vous pouvez passer au
nucléaire -- et avec un peu de chance vous ne construirez pas la prochaine
usine nucléaire sur un magnifique littoral à côté d'une
faille sismique. (Rires) C'est juste une suggestion.
Mais en attendant, pour la prochaine décennie au moins,
le but du jeu ce sont les hydrocarbures. Et que ce soit
le pétrole, que ce soit le gaz, que ce soit le charbon, ce sont les choses avec lesquelles on
travaille. Et avant je passe le temps
qui m'est imparti, voilà ce qui est en train de se passer
dans le système énergétique actuel.
86 % de l'énergie que nous consommons sont des
hydrocarbures. Cela signifie que 86 % des choses que nous
consommons sont probablement des plantes et des
amibes et tout le reste reste fondus. Et la conservation joue
un rôle ici. Il y a une place ici
pour des choses alternatives, mais nous devons également
trouver la bonne autre portion.
Comment nous allons nous occuper de cette autre portion est notre pont
vers le futur. Et quand on pense au pont vers
le futur, une des choses qu'on devrait méditer
est: aujourd'hui nous abandonnons environ deux tiers du pétrole
dans ces puits. Donc nous dépensons une énorme
quantité d'argent et laissons la plus grande partie de l'énergie
là-bas en bas. Ce qui, bien entendu, nécessite plus d'énergie
pour aller chercher de l'énergie. Les ratios deviennent
stupides lorsqu'on en arrive à l'éthanol. Cela pourrait
même être un ratio de un pour un pour l'apport énergétique et
la production d'énergie. C'est une façon stupide de
gérer ce système.
Un dernier point, un dernier graphique. L'une des choses que
nous devons faire est de stabiliser les prix du pétrole. Voilà
à quoi les prix du pétrole ressemblent. OK?
C'est un très mauvais système parce que ce qui arrive c'est que
votre taux de rendement minimum acceptable est placé très bas. Des gens arrivent
avec de très brillantes idées pour les panneaux solaire, ou pour
l'éolien, ou pour quelque chose d'autre, et après devinez quoi?
Le prix du pétrole traverse le plancher. La compagnie
fait faillite, et alors vous pouvez remonter les
prix pétroliers où ils étaient.
Alors si j'avais une modeste suggestion finale,
établissons un prix pétrolier stable en Europe et aux
Etats-Unis. Comment faire? Et bien, fixons
une taxe sur le pétrole qui ne sera pas une taxe de revenus, et qui
dira simplement pour les 20 prochaines années, ce que le prix du
pétrole sera -- ce que vous voulez, 35 dollars, 40
dollars. Si les prix de l'OPEP descendent en dessous de ça, nous les
taxons. Si les prix de l'OPEP montent au dessus de ça, la taxe
s'annule.
Qu'est-ce que ça fait pour les entrepreneurs? Qu'est-ce que ça
fait pour les sociétés? Ça dit aux gens, si vous pouvez
produire de l'énergie pour moins de 35 dollars le baril, ou
moins de 40 dollars le baril, ou moins de 50 dollars
le baril -- discutons-en -- vous aurez une
affaire. Mais ne mettons pas des gens dans ce
cycle où il ne paie pas pour faire de la recherche parce que
votre société fera faillite puisque l'OPEP
mène des alternatives et empêche la bioénergie
de se produire. Merci.